[Applause]
[Music]
mongolia is one of those countries we've
all heard of but no practically nothing
about
[Music]
the world's second largest landlocked
country is as inhospitable as it is
hostile winters can reach minus 40
degrees fahrenheit and are sometimes so
harsh that not even the local livestock
can withstand them in the winter of 2009
for example eight and a half million
cattle perished in the cold that's one
fifth of the country's entire total
[Music]
as you can imagine mongolia is not a
place where life is particularly easy in
fact his extreme climate has meant that
throughout history very few people have
settled in these lands for example
despite being a territory almost three
times larger than a country like spain
and only a little smaller than mexico
its population barely exceeds three
million inhabitants that is we are
talking about one of the most sparsely
populated places on the planet one of
the least inhabited territories and also
one of the poorest however visualpolitik
fans mongolia's luck might be about to
change or at least that's what we're
hoping for all thanks to the gigantic
treasure this country hides beneath its
depths
mongolia is one of the richest mineral
countries in the world we're talking
about copper gold uranium oil and
immense wealth for a sparse population
precisely for that reason at the
beginning of the century as in a way to
escape from poverty the mongolian
government taking advantage of the
economic pool of china a huge devourer
of natural resources set to work to
exploit this enormous wealth once and
for all
[Music]
in this way mongolia became a promising
mining power which unsurprisingly
directs about 90 of its production to
the people's republic of china within a
few years money began to pour into the
country and its economic growth rates
climbed above 10 per year the future
looked promising in a few years mongolia
could be able to join the club of asia's
richest countries but this is 2021 so
the question is has mongolia really
become such a rich and prosperous place
well let's say that if you think that in
lentibar they have replaced water with
champagne and the traditional deal with
a new armani suit you are very very
wrong
[Music]
easy money is not always as profitable
as we think it is plus when virtually
your entire business is basically
dependent on a single client believe me
when i tell you that you're in a much
more compromised position than you might
think so the question is what exactly
happened to mongolia check this out
[Music]
the mongolian dawn
okay pay close attention to this graphic
this will be on the test
what you are looking at is the evolution
of the gdp per capita of mongolia a very
poor country whose economy has
traditionally been linked to a very
rudimentary type of livestock and
agriculture in addition the fall of the
communist bloc inflicted a heavy
economic blow remember that until 1992
mongolia was a satellite state of the
soviet union and yes when it fell a
transition to a democratic free market
model was set in motion but many of the
communist era political and productive
structures survived to make matters
worse there was also the phenomenon of
the oligarchs who took control of former
public companies at almost bargain
basement prices
in 1997 in an attempt to revitalize the
economy and escape the post-soviet
crisis the government passed the
minerals law you know what it changed
everything the law was intended to
encourage private investment
particularly from foreign capital in the
mining sector a sector that until that
time had been dominated mainly by small
producers with very little mechanization
so between 1997 and 2002 the mongolian
government issued almost 3 000
exploration licenses for the creation of
new mines and take note because the
licenses granted covered almost four
percent of the country's entire
territory that's a gigantic country
we're talking about more than 23 000
square miles a little more than 25 of
the surface area of the entire united
kingdom
[Music]
and no most of these licenses did not
end up in the hands of companies from
the country you all have in mind look
for example at the names of some of
these companies the mongolian resource
corporation south gobi resources concora
copper garrison international they don't
sound very chinese do they well the
reason they don't sound chinese is
because they're not most of the
companies that got licensed to explore
and exploit the mongolian sub-soil were
companies from canada and australia a
fruit from the uk switzerland and
various other countries like that in
many cases these companies formed joint
ventures with the mongolian government
itself so the government would benefit
from this activity not only through
taxes and royalties but also through its
own share of the profits it was a
perfect business even more so when
almost all of these minerals that began
to be exploited were exported to a
relatively close neighbor china
especially to the iron and steel
production centers that consumed iron
coal and other minerals as if there was
no tomorrow
[Music]
optimism was sky high in just a few
years foreign investment skyrocketed
from about 10 million in the early 1990s
to more than 800 million at the peak of
the mining boom in 2008. also between
2003 and 2008 exports increased fivefold
to more than 1.8 billion dollars and
don't forget that we are talking about a
country with just over three million
inhabitants in per capita terms these
are huge figures especially if we take
into account that mongolia was one of
the poorest countries in the world
but that would soon change because now
money was pouring in and gdp was growing
at breakneck speed in just a decade the
size of its economy increased tenfold
suddenly investment projects of all
kinds began to spring up and
construction projects flooded the
country mongolia's future looked bright
suddenly
everything stopped mongolia stopped
growing investment stopped and the
country fell into chronic stagnation the
question is why what on earth happened
to make it all go down the drain check
this out
[Music]
mining debacle or political debacle
one thing is clear for mongolia the
mining boom had very significant
benefits that are ongoing there is no
doubt about that however despite this
the frustration is more than evident
[Music]
the 2008 crisis put the entire mongolian
mining model on the ropes the economic
recession halted the investment in
export boom in addition demand and
prices for key minerals plummeted for
example the price of coffer went from
around eight thousand dollars per tonne
in 2007 to around two thousand five
hundred dollars i dropped them almost
seventy percent and practically the same
thing happened with the rest of their
raw materials which meant the government
lost one of its main sources of income
[Music]
suddenly surpluses turned into deficits
especially in terms of trade mongolia
had specialized in the mining industry
which financed a lot of imports of
course this whole process triggered the
public debt and above all the foreign
debt which currently represents 240 the
size of the economy in relatives terms
it's the largest foreign debt in the
world
mongolia fell victim to what is known as
dutch disease that is the mining
industry caused capital to flood into
the country driving both prices and a
local exchange rate through the roof and
because the productivity of the
companies was generally very low rising
labor costs and the unstoppable exchange
rate caused many of these local
companies to go bankrupt
the mongolian economy thus became a
terribly dependent on the commodity
sector and when commodity prices
collapsed the storm was unleashed but
that's not all visualpolitik fans
look according to a world bank report
mongolia has produced 28 billion dollars
worth of minerals since 2004. of this
money the state has taken about 9
billion dollars in taxes over 15 years
at the same time however the government
has been borrowing almost the same
amount 8.7 billion these loans were
secured by the mineral reserve news
themselves remember that we are talking
about a very poor country with a very
small population so this is still a huge
amount of money however in 2019 there
was barely 200 million in the sovereign
wealth fund 200 million dollars of
almost 18 billion dollars a mass since
2004 on account of minerals and yes we
already explained that after the 2008
crisis the budget went into the red but
that math
just doesn't add up so the question is
what on earth did the mongolian
government do with all of the money and
pay attention because this is where the
story gets interesting and this will
also be on the test
[Music]
okay as you can probably imagine
corruption played a pretty important
role yes mongolia is not the most
transparent country in the world and
certainly not the most accessible to be
able to estimate the true extent of
corruption however as a result of leaks
such as the pandora papers it has been
proven that for example the former prime
minister was fond of buying properties
all around the world but no the key to
the missing cash lies not in corruption
but in massive vote buying vote buying
has practically become institutionalized
in mongolian politics for example the
current president okanagan korelshire
yes i know that's not the correct
pronunciation that's not on the test
came to power with the slogan mongolia
owns its resources however far from
working on industrial investment plans
or some political project to boost the
economy the first measure this president
took when he came to power was to shower
pensioners with money that had been his
big election promise to distribute a
pair amongst pensioners financed with
loans guaranteed by raw materials but
why
because pensioners are by far the most
significant voting demographic in
mongolia firstly because there's a lot
of them secondly because they have
common interests and thirdly because
their turnout is much higher than the
rest of the voters so in terms of votes
their influence is enormous and pay
attention because we're not talking
about one remote exception this way of
doing politics has become the norm for
all political parties and yes something
similar could happen in almost every
country in the world but nowhere else
has the buying of votes with promises of
hard cash been taken so far not even in
wait for it
argentina if you're playing
visualpolitik bingo cross that off now
to give you an idea of mongolians 3.2
million inhabitants 2 million receive
regular state funding
the political parties don't need smart
voters who are equipped with critical
thinking they need poor voters who are
easily manipulated with cash when they
need to be geralt's odd ed nabilik
political scientist at mongolian
national university of education in
other words mongolian politicians use
the mineral windfall to gain power the
problem is that the cow is running low
on milk far from boosting development or
building a sovereign wealth fund
mongolian politicians to spend past
present and much of the future mineral
rents on handing out checks left right
and center and i say future because
loans have to be paid back they do oh
god i need to call my bank and all of
this was used to finance checks that are
basically financing imports in the
absence of real reforms
[Music]
so visualpolitik fans the vast natural
wealth gave mongolia a chance to become
very rich country however political
agreed to robbed them of that dream but
having gone to this point it's now over
to you have you ever thought that
natural resources could be a curse how
would you avoid that leave us your
answer in the comments below don't
forget to like and subscribe to
visualpolitik it's very important and if
you like what we do and you want to help
us prove day by day you can help us by
joining our patreon which has various
levels of benefits once again thank you
all very much for watching all the best
and i'll see you next time
[Music]